muy buenos días desde Nueva York sabemos
que los ocupantes son cinco personas
cuatro expertos en la misión y un piloto
Ayer ya conocíamos la identidad de uno
de ellos que se trata de un millonario
británico de 59 años que además tiene al
menos tres récords guinness entre ellos
el récord en tiempo por haber cruzado la
parte más profunda del océano con una
sola inmersión sabemos además que esta
persona hizo una publicación en sus
redes sociales dijo que se iba a
embarcar en la misión para ver los
restos del Titanic con otros dos
legendarios expertos entre ellos al
parecer es un hombre de 73 años francés
el máximo experto mundial podríamos
decir en el Titanic que el que ha
realizado más exploraciones al Titanic
al menos 30 de ellas y les acompañaría
también un hombre o un ciudadano
pakistaní con su hijo de 19 años que
pertenecen a una de las familias más
ricas de Pakistán porque recordemos que
el billete para este viaje tan especial
no es nada barato más de 250 mil dólares
Cuáles son las dificultades que están
enfrentando los equipos para Hallar el
submarino
si entre las dificultades estaría como
decías la falta de oxígeno que se está
acabando poco a poco pero también se
enfrentan Pues a la meteorología al
Estado del mar al hecho de que durante
la noche no hay luz o dificulta las
tareas de búsqueda y de un posible
rescate y luego además también hay que
tener en cuenta que estamos hablando de
aguas a muy baja temperatura en una zona
muy remota que se encuentra a 500
kilómetros de la costa Y eso también
está complicando supone algún tipo de
Reto a la hora de recuperar este
submarino hundido además también no está
confirmado que el sumergible contara con
uno de estos dispositivos auditivos que
avisa a las a los rescatistas de dónde
estaría el submarino Y eso también hace
que todo sea mucho más complicado